all right we're gonna talk Doctor Who
again and big friggin spoiler alert if
you are not caught up on the episodes of
Doctor Who if you have not seen the
episode the name of the doctor go away
still there all right the twist at the
end is what I'm gonna spend pretty much
the whole time talking about I kind of
avoid fan theory so maybe what I'm about
to say has already been said but I want
to throw it out there anyway because if
I end up being right I'd like some
record that I called it and talking
about John Hurt as the doctor so what
does this mean the obvious answer is
that John Hurt is some is effectively
the doctor before he took on the mantle
of the doctor that John Hurt at an
earlier point in the doctor's life did
something in the wake of that action
took on the name of the doctor basically
as a promise to lead a better stronger
more caring life now that's the obvious
interpretation I think it's possible
that John Hurt is not a past version of
the doctor but rather a future version
how did that work because if he's a
future version why is Matt Smith aware
of it he looked at John Hurt he knew who
he was and generally the doctor does not
immediately recognize his future
incarnations and you certainly shouldn't
have the intimate knowledge that the
eleventh Doctor has about this John Hurt
version let's go on back to series three
David Tennant he was talking about being
taken as a child to look into the
untempered schism and he said some would
be inspired someone run away some would
go mad Martha asked him how about you oh
good one to run away I never stroke what
if he's running away from something
specific what if he saw his own future
self do whatever it is that the
character does and so the doctor hasn't
been running from his past rather
running from his future and there's
another thing I want to toss in that
kind of backs this up and that's the
wording of one of the lines that Matt
Smith has the name you choose it's like
it's like a promise you make he's the
one who broke the promise well if this
is a past version of the doctor
he couldn't have broken the promise you
can't break a promise you haven't made
yet so if he's the future version of the
doctor he will ultimately break the
promise that the doctor has made in
taking on that name I'm a little bit
nervous that we're gonna find out
exactly what it is that he did or will
do that said I do think Steven Moffat
understands that the dark needs to
maintain his mystery and he's already
been really clever about giving answers
but not really giving answers I mean
just take the name of the doctor he had
the doctors name be spoken without the
audience actually hearing it which is
also what he did you know back with
silence in the library so I think Steven
Moffat understands that while he can
tease out some really great stories out
of these mysteries it's probably
poisonous to give us full-on answer
which brings me to my second bit of
speculation that I want to do it's
already know that David Tennant and
Billie Piper are coming back for the
fiftieth anniversary I'm calling it that
it's not really the Tenth Doctor that
we're getting we're getting who I tend
to think it was dark - 10.5 the
duplicate that was created in journey's
end yes think about it for a minute
you've got this other version of the
Doctor Who you just bring him without
having to do an excessive amount of time
you wire me a technobabble to get him in
there and explain why the paradox isn't
destroying the world and you've got the
bonus of it's already been established
that this version of the doctor ages
which means they don't have to try and
hide the fact that David Tennant is
visibly older than he was last time he
played the part and ditto for Billie
Piper there you go couple of bits of
speculation
it's gonna be a long way to November but
so worth it so until next time councils
adjourned